hi i'm mallanna i will makeup artists  and if you want to get this winged  eyeliner look then keep on watching for  eyeliner i like to use a felt tip  because it has a thin applicator which  gives you a sharp line first I draw a  line from the outer corner of my eye up  towards where my eyebrow ends i line my  eyes using light strokes to gradually  build up the winged shape a then connect  the tip to the middle of my eye I like  to start off thin so I can easily build  up the thickness don't worry if you make  a mistake you can always go in with a  concealer and brush to clean up for a  defined finish for more videos like this  subscribe to glamour UK's YouTube  channel  [Music]